[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
richter und christian sievers
guten abend in allen es ist der elfte
elfter seit elf uhr elf läuft die
närrische zeit
und am rhein hatten sie einiges
nachzuholen nach dem karneval und fasst
nach dem letzten jahr komplett
ausgefallen waren schunkeln und frohsinn
also
heute ist auch st martin sonne mond und
sterne auch das fiel letztes jahr der
pandemie zum opfer lichter der hoffnung
also und gleichzeitig steigt die zahl
der korona infektionen wieder enorm
erstmals mehr als 50.000 ein neuer
rekordwert für deutschland ärztinnen und
krankenpfleger machen sich verzweifelt
sorgen wie die neuen schweren fälle noch
angemessen behandelt werden können und
was mit all den anderen ist die auf
freie und funktionierende
intensivstationen angewiesen sind feiern
und furcht dass beschreibt dieses land
an diesem tag ein land auf der suche
nach einem plan gegen das was da auf uns
zurollt aus dem bundestag berichtet
weniger
verwaiste plätze angela merkel und olaf
scholz führen ein vier augen gespräch
hinter den kulissen ihr schweigen hatte
in den vergangenen tagen manche
irritiert in zeiten in denen die korona
zahlen im land explodieren reist keiner
der beiden die führung an sich angela
merkel ist die heute geschäftsführend
nur zum zuhören gekommen und olaf scholz
nimmt sich runter auf eine pragmatische
nüchternheit der ihn heute im parlament
niemand übertreffen wird das virus ist
noch unter uns und bedroht die
gesundheit der bürgerinnen und bürger
und deshalb ist es ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir alle maßnahmen ergreifen um
sicher zu sein dass wir die gesundheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger unseres
landes schützen kann auch wenn die lage
anders ist weil so viele geimpft sind
ist sie noch nicht gut ganz besonders
deshalb weil nicht genügend bürger und
bürger von der impfmöglichkeit bisher
gebrauch gemacht haben winterfest solle
das land gemacht werden sagt scholz so
als wäre noch viel vorbereitungszeit mit
3g am arbeitsplatz wieder kostenlosen
kunert es aber eben keinen lockdown mehr
der für das ganze land verkündet wird so
will es vor allem die fdp und die
braucht olaf scholz dass das alte
maßnahmenpaket nicht so bleiben konnte
wie es wahr ist eine frage der
wahrhaftigkeit ich finde wir müssen auch
in der krise unser grundgesetz
respektieren damit wir das bleiben was
wir sind und dass wir sein wollen
nämlich ein freiheitlicher rechtsstaat
meine damen und herren für die union ist
es ein schmaler grat auch entspannen
wollte die sogenannte epidemische lage
beenden war dann zurückgerudert deshalb
ist manche kritik seiner
fraktionskollegen an scholz noch eine
klatsche für sparen es ist kommunikativ
auch das völlig falsche signal dadurch
dass sie die epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite aufheben sagen sie
doch den leuten es ist nicht mehr so
schlimm wir mussten diesen entwurf
vorlegen weil eben nichts vorbereitet
worden ist von ihnen und der
vorgängerregierung das müssen wir jetzt
lachen das ist mir jetzt nacharbeiten
bis zum thema dritte impfung sie können
sich hier nicht draufstehen auf der
verantwortung her bringt aus das ist
schäbig und es ist veraltet und ein
seitenhieb auf schulz die schuldfrage
wird hin und her geschoben die
verantwortung auch die tonlage für die
nächsten wochen stand gesetzt die
hospitalisierung steigt das
infektionsgeschehen explodiert die
dritte impfung muss erst an fahrt
gewinnen die risiken steigen und sie
schrauben den instrumentenkasten runter
das kann nicht gut der scholz nur
zwischen diesen beiden scheint alles in
ordnung olaf scholz hat merkel gar nicht
so sehr widersprochen wie das ok für
eine ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
gegeben auf die sie gedrängt hatte
kleiner sieg für beide großer sieg für
das virus im interregnum lässt es sich
gut ausbreiten
gutes timing ist auch in der politik
goldwert schlechtes timing kann schlimme
folgen haben die neue ampelkoalition die
es ja offiziell noch gar nicht gibt
strikte also im bundestag an einem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz und will weg von
sonder befugnissen für die regierung hin
zu mehr entscheidungen im parlament
sie will die sogenannte epidemische lage
von nationaler tragweite nicht
verlängern das kann man begrüßen als ein
zurück zum normalzustand zum
demokratischen alltag nur dass die
berichte von intensiv medizinerinnen und
klinikchefs gerade jeden tag mehr
klingen eben nach epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite sarah tacke
berichtet
ausgangssperre kontakt verboten zutritt
nur für geimpfte und genesen aus 18
maßnahmen können die länder aktuell
auswählt um auf das corona virus
innerhalb ihrer landesgrenzen zu
reagieren das soll sich nun ändern denn
dieser gesetzentwurf sieht vor dass
schon bald die allermeisten maßnahmen
nicht mehr verordnet werden können vor
allem die besonders harten besonders
einschränkenden regeln sollen wegfallen
nie wieder sollen in einem bundesland
alle schulen dicht gemacht werden können
nie wieder soll verboten werden können
vor die tür zu gehen keine
ausgangssperren mehr und auch keine
kontakt verbote mehr treten die neuen
regeln in kraft kann nicht mehr
untersagt werden mit vielen freunden
ungeimpft und ungetestet in den eigenen
vier wänden zu feiern fatal findet dass
die virologin ulrike protzer
uns muss glaube ich klar sein dass wir
schon mitten in einer vierten welle
stecken oder wir die bremsen wollen ist
es nicht fünf vor zwölf es ist
eigentlich fünf nach zwölf das heißt
jetzt den maßnahmenkatalog
einzuschränken der uns zur verfügung
stellt ist der falsche zeitpunkt und
auch aus juristischer sicht gibt es
keinen grund den ländern so viele
handlungsmöglichkeiten zu nehmen sagt
andrea kießling sie ist expertin im
infektionsschutz recht die
gesetzesänderung ist nicht erforderlich
und könnte auch einfach die epidemische
lage von nationaler tragweite verlängern
und dann einzelne maßnahmen aus der
jetzigen regelung rausnehmen zum
beispiel die nächtlichen ausgangssperren
die wahrscheinlich unverhältnismäßig
sind oder waren aber das heißt nicht
dass man jetzt unbedingt noch mehr
maßnahmen daraus streichen muss aber die
politik will es wild diese 18 maßnahmen
auf nur noch sechs maßnahmen
zusammenkürzen übrig bleiben dann nur
noch unter anderem die sogenannten 2g 3g
regeln dass bundesländer können
weiterhin vorschreibt dass restaurants
theater und kinos nur noch von geimpften
und genesenen betreten werden dürfen
auch das tragen von masken kann
weiterhin vorgeschrieben werden die
sechs maßnahmen die übrig bleiben seien
zwar gut und wichtig aber vielleicht
schon bald nicht mehr ausreichend waren
virologen protzer
2g 3g masken tragen sind sinnvoll aber
um diese massive welle in den griff zu
bekommen brauchen wir ziemlich sicher
auch kontakt beschränkungen wenn man
schaut wo die infektionen passieren dann
passieren sie eben natürlich auf der
arbeit sie passieren in der schule aber
sie passieren sehr sehr viel auch im
privaten bereich
juristin andrea kießling ist hingegen
froh dass einige der besonders harten
maßnahmen gestrichen werden sollen also
ich hätte immer verfassungsrechtliche
bauchschmerzen bei den ausgangs
beschränkungen die hatten wir nicht in
allen bundesländern aber in manchen also
da finde ich durchaus angemessen wenn
man die jetzt aus dem katalog auf
streichen würde in einer sich
verschärfenden kronlage die korona
regeln entschärfen eine politische
entscheidung die rechtlich in dieser
form nicht notwendig und aus
biologischer sicht riskant ist
geschäftsführende lotsen sind noch an
bord ein neuer kapitän noch nicht da und
gleichzeitig so sieht es aus nimmt
dieses staatsschiff volle kraft kurs auf
gefährliche gewässer er gebrauchen ist
der amtierende kanzleramtsminister
genannter braun einen schönen guten
abend wie gut ist so ein regierungs
vakuum für deutschland in dieser lage
das ist natürlich für alle eine
schwierige situation
die krone zahlen haben jetzt ein niveau
erreicht wie wir es noch nie gesehen
haben und deshalb ist es jetzt nicht nur
erforderlich die richtige gesetzgebung
zu machen sondern auch brauchen auch
klare aussagen vor allen dingen ein
gutes miteinander von bund und ländern
und deshalb ist die tatsache dass wir am
donnerstag der nächsten woche zu einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jetzt
endlich zusammen kommen gut und wichtig
aber es ist natürlich sehr sehr spät
jetzt tun heute im bundestag cdu csu
schon so als hätten sie mit dem regieren
eigentlich nichts zu tun wo sind denn
jetzt die klaren regeln aus dem
kanzleramt also ich glaube nicht dass
cdu und csu so tun als hätten sie mit
dem regieren nichts zu tun sondern es
geht hier um eine sehr klare sache
auseinandersetzung die zahlen steigen
dynamisch sie sind sie so hoch wie sie
in dieser pandemie noch nie waren
und die ampelkoalition sagt wir machen
jetzt ein gesetz was den ländern weniger
möglichkeiten gibt auf corona zu
reagieren und das ist in dieser
situation einfach das falsche signal
und auch das falsche ergebnis ja die
ampelkoalition die es ja so offiziell
noch gar nicht gibt die will die
sogenannte epidemische lage nationaler
tragweite nicht mehr verlängern exakt
dasselbe wollte ihr parteifreund jens
spahn vor einiger zeit auch tun jens
spahn hat aber auch das inzwischen sehr
deutlich relativiert schaut man ins
gesetz steht da waren es die epidemische
lage gegeben wenn die whu so etwas
ausruft dass es der fall und wenn es ein
dynamisches infektionsgeschehen einer
gefährlichen krankheit gibt auch das ist
der fall das heißt rein nach dem
wortlaut des gesetzes das der deutsche
bundestag selber geschlossen hat haben
wir eine epidemische lage das heißt sie
hätten diese epidemische lage verlängert
definitiv auch mit allen konsequenzen
die sich daraus ergeben könnten wie zum
beispiel neue schulschließungen neue
kontakt sperren wir haben generelle
schließungen jetzt nicht mehr erwogen
wir haben sie nirgendwo durchgeführt das
heißt wenn ich eine epidemische lage
ausrufe dann besteht die möglichkeit
aber wir mussten sie nicht nutzen weil
wir gerade ein sehr gut wirksamen
impfstoff haben und deshalb ist es
natürlich richtig dass wir das ja auch
heute im deutschen bundestag erfolgt
alle aufrufen sich noch impfen zu lassen
es auch richtig jetzt auf die booster
oder auffrischimpfungen hinzuweisen
aber wenn das infektionsgeschehen so
dynamisch ist wie wir das momentan
erleben dann kann man nicht darauf
warten dass sehr viele menschen sich
impfen lassen sondern müssen die länder
möglichkeiten haben auch beschränkung
maßnahmen zu machen damit nicht schwere
überlastung phänomenen im deutschen
gesundheitswesen passieren ja dran aber
diese möglichkeiten sind da weiter
gegeben nur eben einige die besonders
krass waren und von denen auch
zweifelhaft ist ob sie
verfassungsrechtlich überhaupt bestand
hätten die gibt soll es in zukunft nicht
mehr geben die fdp sorgt heute wir
brauchen eine rechtssichere grundlage
das kann man auch als aufräumen
verstehen von dem was die bisherige
regierung hinterlassen hat nein die
epidemische lage ist eine sehr klare
rechtskonstruktion
wenn sich die ampel koalition
entscheidet eine andere rechtsgrundlage
zu schaffen dann muss man das
respektieren aber die frage ist in den
landkreisen wo jetzt teilweise eine
inzidenz von über 1000 auftritt an die
länder auch möglichkeiten über den
katalog der ampel hinaus sich weitere
notwendige maßnahmen zu überlegen oder
ist der katalog den die ampel vorsieht
abschließend und das ist geplant und das
halte ich für problematisch
sie kritisieren eine regierung die noch
gar nicht im amt ist
gleichzeitig stellt sich aber doch die
frage wieso sind wir überhaupt in so
einer lage überhaupt schon wieder und
diese frage müssen sie sich doch fragen
lassen oder ja ich habe auch im sommer
sehr deutlich gesagt dass ich fest damit
rechne dass nach einem spannenden sommer
wir wieder in einen schwierigen winter
kommen und das liegt an einem sehr
einfachen umstand die delta variante des
virus ist leider sehr sehr ansteckend
und deshalb können wir in einen
entspannten winter nur gehen wenn wir
eine sehr hohe impfquote haben und das
können wir aber momentan auch in
deutschland schon beobachten schauen sie
sich mal die aktuellen zahlen in bremen
an unser bundesland mit den besten
impfquoten da ist die lage deutlich
entspannter vereidigen auch in den
krankenhäusern weil auch geimpfte wenn
sie sich nochmal infizieren sehr selten
heran aber warum hat es die bisherige
regierung nicht geschafft diese
impfquote tatsächlich hoch zu bringen
warum haben sie nicht bisher wenn sie im
sommer sagten bereits diese warnungen
gehabt haben warum haben sie dann
eigentlich nicht genug getan jetzt gibt
jetzt andere länder um uns herum
frankreich spanien zum beispiel die
wundern sich gerade über die deutschen
und sagen warum waren die
warum war die so haben nicht nichts
unternommen haben sehr viel unternommen
aber wir haben natürlich
ein problem und das ist dass die
impfbereitschaft bei uns auch gerade bei
den erwachsenen die im höheren alter
noch etwas zu gering ist also wenn man
sich das anguckt wir gehen davon aus
dass wir etwa 15 millionen erwachsene
noch in deutschland haben die sich nicht
am impfen lassen das sind mehr als
dreimal so viele wie bisher in der
ganzen pandemie kroner durchgemacht
haben und die haben alle das potenzial
noch ohne einen impfschutz einen
schweren verlauf zu bekommen und das ist
einfach zu viel um zu sagen wir haben
die pandemie überwunden sie wollen eine
cdu-chef werden herr braun sich morgen
dazu erklären was können sie besser als
armin laschet also ich hab nicht erklärt
dass ich cdu-chef werden möchte und ich
glaube wenn das jemand werden möchte
dann wird er das sicherlich als erstes
gegenüber seinen mitgliedern erklären
und dann erst damit an die
öffentlichkeit
sie wollen gar nicht cdu-chef werden
glaube das was ich gerade dazu gesagt
habe ist genau das richtige aber sie
grinsen dabei und deswegen gehe ich mal
davon aus dass wir morgen in der sache
von ihnen mehr hören werden für die
mitglieder und auch für die
öffentlichkeit helge braun der
kanzleramtsminister herzlichen dank für
das gespräch wäre gerne
das gespräch einmal kurz vor dieser
sendung aufgezeichnet im heute-journal
update berichtet ein lungenarzt von
seinem tag heute auf einer corona
station am klinikum darmstadt das
nachher heute-journal update erst die
erste nachrichten zusammenfassung heute
abend mit keine server und da bleiben
wir beim thema bei der behandlung von
coop 19 patienten können ärzte sind nun
ein weiteres mittel einsetzen die eu
arzneimittelbehörde ema hat erstmal zwei
antikörpertherapien zugelassen die eine
wurde von der südkoreanischen firma
zählt region entwickelt die andere
gemeinsam vom us-unternehmen regeneron
und dem schweizer konzern roche dieser
hat in den usa bereits seit einem jahr
ein notfall zulassung auch us-präsident
trump wurde damit behandelt in england
gilt seit heute eine impfpflicht für
pflegekräfte ungeimpfte dürfen dort
nicht mehr in alten und pflegeheimen
arbeiten ihnen droht der verlust ihres
arbeitsplatzes
alternativ können sie auch stellen ohne
patientenkontakt versetzt werden laut
dem staatlichen gesundheitsdienst
betrifft das verbot mehr als 50.000
beschäftigte
allerdings gehe man davon aus dass viele
in diesen tagen ihre zweite dosis
erhalten kritiker befürchten dass sich
durch die impfpflicht der pflegenotstand
verschärft
mit einer feierlichen zeremonie hat
frankreich an das ende des ersten
weltkrieges erinnert leben präsident
marco war auch us vize präsidentin
harris gekommen im anschluss sprachen
beide zum auftakt des pariser
friedensforums das hochrangige treffen
dreht sich dieses jahr um die
herausforderungen der korona pandemie
der besuch von harrys gilt als
versöhnungsgeste zwischen frankreich und
den usa hatte es zuletzt streit um einen
geplatzten opel deal mit australien
gegeben
sein name wird wohl immer mit dem von
nelson mandela verbunden sein frederik
willem de klerk der letzte apartheids
präsident südafrikas ist heute gestorben
im alter von 85 jahren erlag er einer
tumorerkrankung
geschichte schrieb der spätere
friedensnobelpreisträger
1990 als er das ende der weißen
herrschaft einleitete es war die rede
seines lebens frederik willem de klerk
der letzte weiße präsident südafrikas
kündigt das ende der rassentrennung an
und die freilassung aller politischen
gefangenen auch die des prominentesten
um es klar zu sagen die regierung hat
unwiderruflich beschlossen nelson
mandela freizulassen ohne bedingungen es
ist der anfang vom ende der apartheid
doch nicht jeder will sich damit
anfreunden
blutige unruhen brechen aus das land
steht kurz vor einem bürgerkrieg
die gewalt endet erst mit den wahlen
1994 aus den nelson mandela als klarer
sieger hervor geht im mai 1994 wird er
der neue präsident südafrikas
bigler bleibt als vizepräsident an
seiner seite zieht sich später aber aus
der politik zurück für ihren
versöhnungswillen und ihren mut
erhielten sie 1993 den
friedensnobelpreis
auf die frage ob er etwas in seinem
leben bedauere sagte die khl ab zuletzt
dass wir nicht früher in unserer
geschichte von der apartheid zu einem
gerechteren system gewechselt haben
es war die herausforderung seines lebens
das er sich selbst entmachtete als er
den weg für mandela ebnete war die
krönung seiner politischen karriere
wir gucken jetzt knapp 1000 kilometer
weit nach osten so weit ist das also gar
nicht weg die ostgrenze der europäischen
union zwischen polen und belarus wo sich
seit längerem eine krise anbahnt die
jetzt eskaliert die nachbarländer
litauen estland lettland warnten vor
militärischen auseinandersetzungen es
geht um den vorwurf der eu der
belarussische machthaber alexander
lukaschenko betreibe ein zynisches spiel
mit menschen in not tatsache ist
tausende migranten sitzen an der grenze
fest bei eisigen temperaturen und ohne
aussicht auf eine lösung hanna faist ist
dort
sie hat ein eigenes straßenschild die
polnische sperrzone kurz vor der grenze
zu weißrussland durchfahrt nur für
anwohner berichterstatter sind
ausgeschlossen bella russisches fernseh
material gibt einen eindruck wie
verzweifelt die lage für die migranten
sein muss
an diesem morgen treffen wir menschen
aus dem nord irak und syrien dies doch
nach polen geschafft haben und nun in
einer sicheren unterkunft auf ihr
asylverfahren war
es gab nichts in weißrussland kein essen
kein trinken aber hier ist es gut
die töchter und die schwangere frau sind
erschöpft tage lang war die familie aus
dem nordirak der kälte ausgesetzt
auch josef atala ist erleichtert hier zu
sein der syrer sei von bella russischen
soldaten verprügelt worden dann folgte
eine tagelange odyssee durch den wald
wir mussten aus dem sumpf trinken wasser
aus dem sumpf mit taschentüchern haben
wir das gefiltert und es getrunken
das klingt fürchterlich
[Musik]
auch scham aus dem nordirak habe es acht
mal probiert über die grenze den letzten
versuch hatte mit dem handy dokumentiert
300 menschen seien an einem waldrand
versammelt worden in der nacht seien
dann bella russische soldaten zur gruppe
gekommen
sie hatten ein nachtsichtgerät und auch
einen draht schneider bei sich um den
zaun zu öffnen die sind dann nach hinten
gegangen und haben zu uns gesagt geht
jetzt
und wir sind gegangen
kurz vor der grenzüberquerung sollen die
soldaten pillen unter den migranten
verteilt haben erzählt er schlafpillen
für die kinder dass sie nicht auffallen
und ruhig sind wenn sie über die grenze
gehen und sie hatten andere pillen für
die die nicht laufen können zum
aufputschen dass sie es auch über die
grenze schaffen
er hat es zwar geschafft doch die
entscheidung so zu fliehen bräutigam
ich habe meinen landsleuten gesagt auch
wenn man euch geld dafür bietet kommt
nicht hierher glaubten nicht dieser weg
ist der weg des todes
joseph atala aus syrien sieht das anders
er ist voller hoffnung auf ein neues
leben in europa ob er es wieder wagen
würde
auf jeden fall ich spreche nur für mich
ich habe zwei töchter und eine frau
wegen ihm bin ich denn das leben in
syrien ist einfach nicht sicher
in den wäldern an der grenze haaren
immer noch tausende migranten wie scham
und josef aus ihnen stehen polen
sicherheitskräfte gegenüber die europas
ostgrenze sichern
und wir gucken mal auf weitere
nachrichten jetzt mit server und da
stellen wir die frage wie viel geld
werden die ampel parteien für ihre
regierungspläne zur verfügung haben die
antwort gab es heute vom arbeitskreis
steuerschätzung und sie fiel
optimistisch aus laut der prognose
fließen im laufenden jahr insgesamt
38,5 milliarden euro mehr in die kassen
als bei der letzten schätzung im mai
erwartet bis 2025 würden bund länder und
kommunen insgesamt
179 milliarden mehr einnehmen
relativ wenig steuern zahlt in der eu so
manch ein großkonzern auch weil die
transparenz vorgaben bisher viel raum
dafür lassen das soll sich nun ändern
nach jahrelangem streit haben sich die
eu institutionen auf schärfere regeln
geeinigt was genau soll sich denn jetzt
ändern frank bethmann er zumindest mit
der großen geheimniskrämerei wer wo wie
viel oder wie wenig steuern zahlt soll
jetzt schluss sein die strengeren eu
auflagen sollen für mehr einblick sorgen
die steuerdaten der großen
multinationalen konzerne werden künftig
für jeden öffentlich gemacht etwa auf
den internetseiten der unternehmen in
form eines detaillierten bericht ist
fordert die eu ein dass die konzerne
unter anderem ihre netto umsätze den
gewinn vor steuern und die tatsächlich
gezahlten ertragsteuern in den
jeweiligen ländern angeben müssen eine
transparenzoffensive mit dem ziel den
druck auf die firmen zu erhöhen zahlen
sie angemessen steuern oder entziehen
sie sich dieser aufgabe jahr für jahr
nutzen große multi es legale
steuerschlupflöcher verdienen millionen
doch zahlen häufig nur wenige
zehntausend euro steuern mehr als 50
milliarden euro verloren die eu-staaten
durch steuervermeidung jährlich einer
aktuellen schätzung zufolge die
strengere richtlinien ist ein steuer
pranger eine anklage durch offenlegung
wer aber denkt die eu auflagen sind eine
direkte verpflichtung für konzerne mehr
steuern zu zahlen der irrt
steuergesetzgebung ist sache der
einzelnen mitgliedstaaten so lange aber
eu länder wie malta zypern oder irland
mit niedrig steuersätzen doggen kann die
heute verabschiedete regelung nur ein
anfang sein die frankfurter börse
jubel im westafrikanischen benin nach
jahrelangem streit hat frankreich 26
kunst und kultur objekte zurückgegeben
hunderte menschen aus ganz berlin kamen
zum feierlichen empfang am
präsidentenpalast mit den artefakten
kehrten seele und identität zurück so
präsident teilungen französische
soldaten hatten die gegenstände ende des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts geraubt ihre
rückgabe gilt als richtungsweisend für
den umgang mit afrikanischer beutekunst
die nächsten updates werden aus dem
orbit kommen wir so was twittert hat
großes vor wie der nächste deutsche
astronaut matthias maurer er und drei
weitere sind gerade auf dem weg ins
weltall mehrfach musste der start
verschoben werden aber jetzt sind die
vier im anflug auf die internationale
raumstation das größte menschengemachte
objekte im all die iss bringt es mit
ihren ausgeklappten sonnensegeln auf 109
meter war wird die nächsten sechs monate
vor allem hier arbeiten im columbus
modul der europäischen raumfahrt-agentur
ein hightech labor dass wir uns mal ein
bisschen genauer anschauen können und in
dem seit 2008 geforscht wird ein großer
teil davon mit deutscher beteiligung
über maurers mission mit dem schönen
namen cosmic kiss berichtet susanne
freitag
der puristische look in schwarz weiß ist
nicht das einzige kennzeichen einer
neuen ära der raumfahrt matthias maurer
unterschreibt an einer raumkapsel der
privaten firma spacex von ihren masken
sie ist mehrfach verwertbar billiger er
ist der zweite europäer der mit dem
amerikanischen unternehmen fliegt europa
muss stärker werden im all sorgt er
das thema raumfahrt ist zu groß so
wichtig das sind die zukunftsmärkte und
wir müssen als europa schauen dass wir
hier weiter investieren damit uns nicht
da die amerikanischen firmen wie spacex
boeing virgin galactic blue origin die
alle schon technologie haben menschen
ins all zu transportieren
dass die uns da nicht abhängen
crew 3 am morgen erfolgreich gestartet
endlich
der erfolg ihrer mission ist auch ein
erfolg für die vielen neuen anbieter auf
dem rad markt rund um die stadt rampen
boomt die weltraum wirtschaft in amerika
wird geschätzt zehnmal so viel
investiert wie in europa
danach den europas ist zum einen dass
wir nicht wie in amerika zum beispiel so
schnell sind um diese ideen umzusetzen
in kommerzielle erfolge zum anderen auch
der zugang zu geld ist in europa gilt
knapper und viel schwieriger zu
organisieren
das ist orbital rief diese animation
zeigt wie milliardär jeff bezos sich
seine raumstation vorstellt für forscher
aber auch für touristen warum nicht
gar nicht so abwegig sagen sie hier bei
one web satellites eine firma in cape
canaveral die kleinere satelliten in
serie herstellt und vom weltraum boom
profitiert
sind zehn jahren kann ich mir vorstellen
dass es hier von von cape canaveral
weltraumtourismus geht ja und die leute
ist einmal von disney über cruise ships
sind zum weltraum alles erleben können
es wäre doch
ein wunderbarer flug unglaubliches
erlebnis das für q3 vorhin aus der
kapsel an die erde sie sind zum arbeiten
hier oben die schwerelosigkeit macht
viele ihrer experimente erst möglich
wir waren schon mal aus dem fenster
geguckt und die aller ersten fotos
gemacht und zu trainieren fotos von uns
wie wir schweben sowie kinder gerade
wenn alles läuft wie geplant werden sie
um ein uhr morgens ankommen dann werden
sie hier sechs monate leben und arbeiten
auf der iss dem höchsten forschungslabor
der erde
so und mitarbeiter haben wir euch auf
der erde unsere ganz eigene probleme
natürlich pandemie ohne politik erst
sorglos jetzt planlos das thema der
spannenden runde bei maybrit illner
gleich unter schließt sich der kreis
wieder zu dem womit wir heute abend
begonnen haben bis morgen und noch einen
schönen abend
[Musik]
guten abend die hochdruckbrücke
zerbricht jetzt wenigstens vorübergehend
und so kann sich am wochenende dieses
tief zu uns rein schummeln dann regnet
es nicht nur ganz im norden sondern auch
mal im westen und im süden deutschlands
außerdem regenwolken gab es heute aber
noch was viel spannenderes und das war
der zähe nebel der sich zb an der donau
am oberrhein aber auch an der mosel gar
nicht mehr auflöst so lagen die
temperaturen im nebel nur bei zwei grad
am alpenrand wurden ist 18 grad fast
unglaublich heute nacht sinken die werte
auf +3 bis -2 grad es wird frostig am
boden und es droht wieder reifglätte im
norden bleibt es bei 8 bis 5 grad milder
das liegt an den dichteren wolken dort
die allerdings nur noch selten regen
dabei haben in der mitte und im süden
ist es entweder klar dass bildet sich
nebel und der hält sich morgen dann auch
zum teil wieder zu an den nordrändern
der mittelgebirge und am alpenrand sehen
sie dagegen häufiger die sonne und auch
in norddeutschland kommt sie öfter mal
zum zuge nur in ihr zwischen der
uckermark und nordfriesland bleibt es
wohl eher bedeckt so liegen die
höchsttemperaturen morgen in
norddeutschland bei 7 bis 11 grad im
dauer grau sind es nur 3 bis 7 grad am
alpenrand 14 und am samstag kommt dann
dieses kleine tiefer an das verlässt uns
am sonntag dann südwärts und die neue
woche die startet wieder mit ruhigem
novemberwetter bei sechs bis zwölf grad
und wie sie hier am temperatur und
wolken trend für berlin sehen können
bleibt es mit diesen ruhigen
novemberwetter wohl bis zum 26 11
ähnlich guten abend